well look in this one I'm going to
answer the personal question so I
figured I'll just get comfortable right
off the bat okay second half of the Q&A
and this one I'm gonna deal with be
general opinion questions and as well as
what I consider the personal questions
and you know about more about me than my
tastes or my feelings on various geeky
things so let's get right to this
what is the worst movie you have ever
seen probably robot monster I did i
watch that because they think it's so
bad it's funny I don't I think it just
hurts what's the weirdest move you've
ever seen nowhere also an experience I
don't recommend is there an opinion that
you have that has changed drastically
this was a hard one for me to call cuz
it probably has but like my penis tend
to change over time it's very rare that
I have something that's like Oh snaps me
into a complete change from before but I
think overall probably my assessment of
how much I like David Tennant's doctor
he is actually dropped quite a bit in my
assessment I still like him but he used
to be like right up there towards the
top remain he's really not on anymore
most unpopular movie opinion The Shining
isn't scary popular film series you just
can't get into I looked up like some of
the most successful franchises in series
of films and some of the ones that were
on that list that I've never really been
able to get into or couldn't finish were
Transformers Hunger Games and The Fast
and the Furious series which youtubers
would you recommend I could actually
recommend a lot I could do a rather
lengthy list but I'll try and keep it a
little bit short I'm gonna go with five
of these so Cinna fix they do a fair
number of lists but I think the way that
they construct and execute those movie
lists is a lot smarter than most places
that do list including me
Nick Marie Willis just really fun
animations really funny really enjoyable
Lindsay Ellis who basically does the
best you know video essays
on YouTube and part of the reason I
don't try and do that format because
between her and some other people I'm
like I'm never gonna be that good at it
just right there are a number of YouTube
channels that I like a lot that focus on
writing and and approaches to narrative
but this is one of the ones that has
some of the lesser subscribers versus
some of the other ones that I like as
well and I feel I feel like it deserves
more recognition than it currently gets
and a recent one this was another video
essayist but she's she's young and she's
fresher and I'm really excited to what
she's gonna see what she's gonna do
later what I'll see from her Sara Z so
those are five that I think are worth
checking out if you like me and my stuff
if you don't obviously you won't like
that stuff but you know that's how it is
more specifically I was also asked about
my favorite YouTube reviewers so again
I'll just stick to five I could easily
do a lot more than that
there's Jeremy John's that's in there
mainly in terms of influence I mean
early on you know I used a green screen
I didn't deliberately try and ape him
but seeing what he did was kind of an
influence in terms of my working out
this format of me ranting at the camera
movie Bob I don't always agree with him
but I always find him interesting and
entertaining yatzee Crowe Shaw of zero
punctuation again don't always agree
with him but man he's fun Stu bagful
probably my favorite Doctor Who YouTube
reviewer and also snez drunk because he
focuses on 16-bit mostly and that's
that's my gaming Golden Age what shows
do you watch that aren't really geek
related all right I'm gonna give a
couple of shows that have ended in a
couple of ones that are still running so
a few examples would be house
Hannibal Brooklyn nine-nine dear white
people crazy ex-girlfriend and the
unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt what's your
favorite Shrek movie everyone has one
don't lie I won't lie I think the first
two Shrek movies are genuinely good but
the second one's the best I'm an
aspiring sci-fi writer and my question
for you is this what do you think of the
and don'ts when it comes to putting
social issues in your writing now this
is actually interesting to me because
I've had a number of writers or aspiring
writers kind of reach out to me since
I've started tackling the LGBTQ topics
more yeah INRI in some recent months so
I I don't have I'm not a published
writer so you know take anything that I
say with a grain of salt um especially
considering that I've been trying to get
stuff published and haven't succeeded
yet but in any case what I would say is
the the easiest pitfall to that you
could fall into in terms of trying to do
social issues in sci-fi is coming at it
from a perspective of here's this social
issue how do I make a sci-fi story about
it that is how you tend to end up with
pandering pretentious or patronizing
stories if you instead just focus on a
narrative focus on a story focus on
characters in a world that intrigue you
and that you want to tell and delve into
and then if within that narrative you
can find opportunities to integrate and
address social issues that's where
that's where it builds on the narrative
and deepens the story as opposed to the
story being an excuse for you to just
spout your stance on a social issue for
however long it takes for you to get
through it so just be cautious about not
putting the cart before the horse
story comes from story is king in my
book story always comes first
your themes should complement it but if
you start with theme first and try and
build a story around it that tends to
not go as well what do you think would
have happened to the comic book movie
industry if Tim Burton's Superman lives
and George Miller's Justice League
mortal were made I think very little
would have changed if Tim Burton's
Superman lives had been made I think it
probably would have had a similar sort
of response that Superman Returns
received not necessarily for the same
reasons but I think overall responsible
have been about the same and add that at
the point that movie would have been
made I don't think it would have had a
huge impact justice league mortal on the
other hand if it had been good and it
was George Miller
decent shot then it could have put DC
completely ahead of Marvel and DC
wouldn't still be trying to play
catch-up and whether you like the DC
movies or not you cannot deny that they
have been trying to catch up to Marvel
and The Avengers and that kind of thing
you're right from the get-go and a lot
of the decisions that I think where
mistakes seem to have stemmed from
trying to play catch-up and if Justice
League mortal have been made could have
flipped the entire dynamic on its head
but we'll never know now which movie
have you seen the most times
ghostbusters if you could read only one
book watch one movie one Doctor Who
episode it and have one CD for the rest
of your life what would they be now
before I get my answers these are not
necessarily my all-time favorites of any
of these they're just the ones that I
think I could revisit the most often
before I would be completely sick of
them and that's that is slightly
different from absolute favorite so
those so again that is book movie doctor
episode and CD so they'd be restaurant
at the end of the universe
ghostbusters city of death and the
original Broadway cast recording of a
rant where would you rather live North
Korea or some Bob way during the Mugabe
era I honestly don't know enough about
the situation's and either of those to
answer that question favorite Disney
songs
I'm just got again I'll rattle off a few
who you are from Moana part of your
world from The Little Mermaid friends on
the other side from Princess and the
Frog Portobello Road from Bedknobs and
Broomsticks as long as you cut out sort
of the dance interlude in the middle of
it and this one might be cheating but
I'm gonna do it anyway Shadowland from
the stage version of The Lion King are
you reading any current comic book
series no I am not I haven't picked up
monthlies since the 90s do you have any
smokes the smoke theories no I don't do
you have a favorite filmmaker I actually
don't I have a list of filmmakers who I
always keep an eye on and I try to
eventually get around to seeing
everything they've made I have
couple gaps to some of these but some of
those filmmakers that will be folks like
guillermo del toro christopher nolan
darren aronofsky those are folks who are
always at worst they're interesting and
when you can always at least be
interesting and not boring that i know
i'm gonna keep an eye on you who is your
favorite Star Wars character Leia Organa
princess our general whatever your
preferred title for her is what are your
what are five creative works you think
everyone should read see or experience
now I'm gonna answer this slightly
off-centre like the answer I'm gonna
give us not exactly what was asked
because I don't like to deal in to
finish they like everyone must see this
like anything and whatever listen are
that declarative it tends to annoy me
because you know there are things that I
know impacted me greatly but depending
on who you are your background and the
sort of things that inherently appeal to
you they they might not do it for you
you know I you can recommend to me you
know the best sushi sushi restaurant on
the planet I still don't like sushi I'm
still not gonna have a life-changing
experience going there so what I'm what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna offer up five
pieces of art or media that had
incredibly significant impacts on me and
I I think are worth at least looking
into for folks to see if it looks like
something maybe you'd enjoy and if it is
I I can't recommend them enough so those
would include the play Equus the book
The Last Unicorn the film The Rocky
Horror Picture Show the music album Pink
Floyd's the wall and basically almost
every incarnation of The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy
now that the trailer for record Ralph to
has come out and shows that the movie
will have a mega crossover of gives knee
princesses it is pertinent to ask which
of them is your favorite growing up it
was Ariel but I might need to address
this in an animation junkie at some
point I
I've gotten older there are some really
serious problems that I have with the
Little Mermaid so I'm not sure I can
pick that one and goo conscious anymore
because some of those problems do
revolve around her specifically as a
character I do still really like her
though so it leaves you in position
where I'm not sure because I I feel like
I'm not sure I can say it's her anymore
but nobody has definitively moved up
into that slot I mean maybe Moana but
that's like by default if you would have
made the Justice League movie what
characters would have been on the team
okay I'm actually gonna answer this in
two ways I'm gonna give my answer for
who I would have put on the team for the
Justice League movie coming off of
Batman V Superman but I'm also gonna
give the lineup of who who I would want
in a Justice League movie that had no
ties to previous continuity that I would
just have them like I don't have to
worry about what was done before this is
who I I would personally put so for the
one coming off the back of Batman V
Superman would have been Wonder Woman
Batman Martian Manhunter the Wally West
version of flash and for tech support
Oracle and if I had my say like and I
could completely ignore previous you
know continuity not have to worry about
you know who was already established in
a universe or whatever it would be
Wonder Woman
Martian Manhunter Jason blood aka the
demon Green Lantern and Hawkgirl any
books you would like to see adapted into
films yeah anything by Christopher Moore
please what how would you have made the
DC EU films a one at a time like not
lock in and start filming on something
that is directly following on from a
film before you even know how the
general public reacts to it the whole
cycle needed to be slowed down and
that's not to say that it couldn't have
been developing multiple movies at the
same time but they what they should not
have that what they should not have done
and I knew this right off the bat they
should not have been making films that
directly followed on from whatever they
did and we're filming that in
conjunction the reason that Marvel has
gotten away with having multiple movies
in production at the same time is cuz
they are in separate franchise so you
know we had Thor and the first door in
the first Captain America coming out
fairly close to each other but they were
independent one did not have to be built
off the back of the other because when
you do it like that if the one that
comes out first turns out to not connect
with audiences then the one you've
already made is in trouble which is
exactly what happened with Justice
League so slow it down and if they and
if they were going to insist on multiple
things in production at the same time
they were going to have to start out way
less connected what is the best
opportunity that you have seen for LGBTQ
representation in geek media that hasn't
been taken advantage of who is sitting
on the most obvious leaping off point
but still not taking the shot this is a
really interesting question and I wish I
had an answer to it unfortunately my
brain just my brain really doesn't work
that way I I you know I'll evaluate
whatever inclusions representations get
put in there but I can't sort of come at
things and going that really should have
been this instead that was a golden
opportunity to do this when it comes to
things like like that kind of inclusion
I just I tried really hard I couldn't
get into the headspace to be able to
answer this which annoys because it was
actually a really good question do you
think there are any black mayor episodes
that are better than Heaven Sent
probably but at the same time I haven't
had a black mayor up so that's taking me
on the on quite an emotional journey to
rival it and by that I'm not saying I
haven't watched a black mayor episode
that has had the same way I had as much
emotional impact as heaven-sent but I do
mean the emotional journey because when
when black mayor episodes hit me they
hit me hard but they hit me hard you
know either sinking me down really low
or on very rare occasions you know
raising me up but having said managed to
do both it sank me down really low and
then shot me into the stratosphere
triumphantly within a matter of minutes
of each of those two emotions and I
actually can't think of anything else
that has managed to do that do you like
any old movies from the 50 60 70 yeah so
just rattling off some just some
examples from 50s singing in the rain
North by Northwest 12 Angry Men 60s
Planet of the Apes The Great Escape
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid 70
Star Wars Godfather jaws Rocky Horror
Picture Show
do you like Harry Potter I have to
assume whoever asked this has not says
not seeing me do a Harry Potter
discussion decked out in my Slytherin
gear yeah yeah I like Harry Potter what
are your top 5 favorite TV shows Doctor
Who
Gotham the max escaflowne and Batman the
Animated Series were you surprised that
Disney had Darth Maul's show up in the
solo film where do you think that's
going well as far as where it's going
it's there obviously just setting him up
to be a villain in another side story
whether it is it's a sequel to solo
specifically or something else that that
was obviously where they were going with
that was I surprised only insofar as I
was surprised that anybody thought it
was a good idea movies news shows that
are popular or considered classics that
you just didn't enjoy or hated and or
movies and shows that weren't popular or
famous that you strongly suggest I'm
gonna kind of skip this first one
because there's a later question that is
very similar to the same thing and but
also I don't I don't like just kind of
crapping on something that I know a lot
of other people like unless I have a
point so I'm kind of iffy to do that I
will mention though a TV show that I
loved that I know that so many other
people seem to not and it really knows
the heck out of me the Muppets the ABC
show the one from a couple of years ago
I loved it I loved it right off the bat
I loved it even more after I got
retooled midseason and I will never
understand people's hang-ups and
objections to that I thought it was
great and you all suck for not watching
it so it got cancelled after one season
do you think Star Wars will land to the
do you think star do you think Star Wars
will oh my god do you think Star Wars
will end up getting the same fate of the
DCE you after solo I have to assume they
mean like completely restructuring and
changing the original plan because
otherwise I'm not sure what they mean by
the fate of the DC EU because that's
I mean it's not like it went anywhere
but I'm gonna say probably not unless
episode 9 under perform solo itself is
like the first box office hiccup as far
as this thing goes I think it's gonna
take two before they really start doing
a massive course correction what's one
thing you regret watching more than
anything else the haunted world of L's
super beast Oh decently animated but
what a waste of people's talents holy
crap what do you prefer comic books or
manga cartoons or anime you know I
ultimately I'm gonna favor the Western
stuff you know cartoons and and Western
comics I do love anime I do love manga
but there are certain tropes within
those mediums that just annoy me and or
that I guess I just kind of don't yet so
if you're gonna force me to choose one
of the other I that's the way I'm gonna
go but I'm not sure why I should have to
if you could live for a year and not
have to worry about being killed or
seriously injured in any fictional
universe what would it be so assuming
that I'm just me and not like I can be
in the Marvel Universe and have
superpowers assuming that I just stay as
I am now I would go with Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy because I would be
really cool with bumming around the
universe hitching rides and trying to
get free drinks if you could be any race
in any universe what would it be and why
any race that does shape-shifting
because it's the best superpower are you
excited to see Star Wars Episode nine
more morbidly curious at this point I
think a favorite Star Trek captain and
why the card because he's the one I grew
up on and I don't really have a deeper
answer than that I know that's the
reason are you into cinema much like
certain directors such as David Lynch
the Coen brothers or David Fincher and
relatedly do you have a favorite artsy
movie so I assume by cinema the question
or did mean you know the the more sort
of art house style but I mean the the
ones that
they mentioned aren't like total
avant-garde they are kind of brushing up
against mainstream but in general most
of the things that people tend to go oh
that's not a movie that's cinema are
things that I can often appreciate the
the artistry the technical skill I can
appreciate that they are good pieces of
art as a rule of thumb I just don't
enjoy them as much as things like
superheroes and Star Wars and you know I
I enjoy I suppose from an artistic
standpoint lesser entertainment what can
I say if as far as a favorite artsy
movie goes I suppose there's a number of
options I could go with it would
probably be the fountain
now which spider-man villain do you
prefer as Spidey's arch-nemesis venom or
Green Goblin well if you're gonna make
me choose between those two I'll go
Green Goblin but honestly for me I'd
rather have Doc Ock what do you think is
the deepest most artistic and quality
superhero film now I'm not entirely sure
why it something has to be all three of
those but by those criteria I would say
probably Logan if you could argue for or
defend any superhero that a film that
was unpopular what would it be a
Punisher war zone like I get why
mainstream audiences didn't like it I
even get my critics didn't like it I
will never get my comic book fans who
claim to like The Punisher crap all over
this movie I will never understand I
love it
what cartoon anime or anime do you think
is underrated and would like to
recommend and likewise is there a
live-action show well as far as an
animated thing I you know well if you
can roll with a certain amount of
surrealism I will always recommend the
max as far as live-action goes that's a
tougher call for me because most of the
live-action stuff I enjoys fairly you
know it's not unknown it's not obscure I
kind of want to say the the TV series
action which was cancelled after a
season except I mean yeah I got a stick
in asterisks on that cuz I haven't
revisited it in a while and it deals in
the kind of
that I feel is probably aged badly and
it might honestly be really problematic
at this point and I honestly don't know
but yeah maybe that one
are you a Pokemon fan if so do you have
a favorite Pokemon and not really I
never watched the show only Pokemon game
I ever played was pokemon yellow back on
the original Gameboy and I didn't even
finish it
what podcasts do you subscribe to a boy
quite a few so again I'm just gonna do
some highlights here since I have a
podcast on the fire and water Network I
am subscribed to a whole bunch of shows
on that but my favorite out of that
Network and pretty much all that's worth
checking out my favorite on that network
is a hot mu or not on there's also
relatively geeky your brain on facts
improvised weapons which full disclosure
one of the people on that is a co-host
on one of my podcasts wait wait don't
tell me and radio versus the Martians do
you prefer comic books or novels
I prefer novels but I read more comic
books just because of I rarely have the
time to dedicate to getting three novels
anymore actually know what will split
the difference let's go graphic novels
most underrated movie of all time of all
time really I don't know maybe
Mirrormask most overrated movie of all
time I did to it already The Shining
seriously I I don't get it what's worse
DC EU or Disney Star Wars right now as
of recording it's the DC EU it's
probably worth asking again after
Aquaman and episode 9 come out though do
you think Aquaman will flop um I have no
idea at this point I I really don't it
it doesn't have to it's not a foregone
conclusion it isn't it is gonna be an
uphill battle though I think it's gonna
be a tough sell but I honestly don't
know what's your favorite guilty
pleasure movie Masters of the Universe
like the 80s he-man movie the one with
Dolph Lundgren do you have a favorite
book series people might have already
guessed Hitchhiker's Guide
Galaxy what's your favorite and least
favorite episodes and seasons of Game of
Thrones so far okay favorite episodes
it's a toss-up between the laws of God
men and the door least-favorite it's a
toss-up between the bear and the maiden
fair and unbowed unbent unbroken my
favorite season so far a season for my
least favorite is season 3 which I know
is controversial because it was like aa
red wedding like the red wedding is fine
but you know I do I have a lot of issues
with the rest of that season if you had
to rewatch the season finale of lost or
Dexter on a loop for 24 hours what would
it be lost because the season series
finale for Dexter was the worst series
finale in the history of series finales
it is toxic sludge that needs to just be
melted down into a solid rod and then
shot into the Sun I know this makes no
sense but god I hate that thing have you
ever heard the tragedy of Darth Plagueis
the wise see what you did there if you
had to be stuck in an episode of black
Mara which one would it be
I'm gonna say hang the DJ but that's on
the presumption that I'm not actually
like one of the people stuck in the
simulation but rather I'm one of the
real-world versions do you know who the
Justice Society of America are and have
you read any of their comics I do know
who they are I have not actually read
their comics that's actually true for me
for a lot of comic-book stuff I am
friends with a lot of comic book people
I enjoyed reading about what's going on
I enjoy you know talking about all that
so I am often fairly not not like deep
knowledgeable but decently knowledgeable
about a lot of comic book stuff very
little event I've actually read like
directly so it's kind of weird what is
your favorite LGBTQ of film and/or
documentaries this is gonna be a really
cheesy answer because it is kind of a
cheesy movie it's kind of a trashy movie
I really do love bound I like it a lot
and I think Gina Gershon takes the James
Dean mantle as the embodiment of
masculine sex you just look at her in
that film
like oh my god yeah if you've never seen
bound sea-bound seriously any advice for
a Star Wars fan who enjoys the new movie
but is getting pissed off from the
ongoing harassment of other fans avoid
the Internet
failing that avoid the communities were
you seeing it happen the most that's all
I can offer all right now I've got sort
of a a lightning round here so people
just ask for a bunch of my thoughts on
Barry stuff but I actually am NOT gonna
do all the stuff that was asked for me
there was like somebody who gave me like
a whole list of Farscape episodes asking
for my specific thoughts and that that
was too much I mean I love Farscape but
I'm not adapt that whoa that was a
little overkill so let me just burn
through these amazing world of gumball
I've only seen a little bit of it I
found it fun though a Boardwalk Empire
haven't seen it 0 punctuation I
mentioned it already I do watch it I
like it a lot Breaking Bad it's great
camp camp no clue what that is three
colors red haven't seen it only three
colors one I've seen is blue but that
was so long ago I barely remember it
scar alien vids I don't know what that
is better call Saul haven't watched it
yet How to Train Your Dragon TV series
I've only seen a couple of episodes I
did like them but I haven't had the time
to dig into that Titan AE man that was a
movie that I wanted to like so bad and
it just didn't work
angry video game nerd I've seen like a
little of his stuff it's it's just not
quite my bag Hamilton um this is bad for
for a guy who likes theater and actually
does theater locally Hey to worry Liz
I'm gonna lose credit on that Avatar The
Last Airbender I also haven't gotten
around to seeing that yet either it's
one of those things been on the to-do
list forever it keeps getting bumped the
prisoner I've actually seen both
versions the original and the new one
original one is bizarre as hell and I'm
not entirely sure what to think about it
other than groundbreaking the second one
was a waste
I had one really good line but it was
not a good show gravity falls
haven't seen it Star Wars the Clone Wars
haven't seen him Bionicle
xena Rick and Morty I've seen three
episodes I can't get into it it's the
characters
I don't enjoy spending time with these
characters spongebob it's okay actually
kind of like the movie but the shows
just you know it's fine and Steven
universe another thing I haven't gotten
around to so we're gonna wrap this whole
thing up with the personal questions so
let's get into those why do you think
toxic fandoms are so prevalent today I
think it's just access to platforms i
I've been thinking about this a bit
recently and people are like god fans
have gotten that I think they've always
been like this I can remember back when
I was a kid
slightly older Star Wars fans being very
cool like directly not just like behind
the backs like being openly cruel and
mocking towards younger Star Wars fans
who liked he walks I this stuff has
always been there it's just now thanks
to the internet everybody has a platform
and they're able to find and amplify the
voice of like-minded people a lot better
than they used to what were your dreams
as a kid and how did they change as you
got older if they change yeah they've
shifted a little so what I was young I
really wanted to be an actor that that
was after I realized that I couldn't
actually be Michael Jackson um and at
this point I think in a way that's kind
of funneled into this because this you
know this and and you know burlesque
performance which I do are are my
outlets to still be able to perform how
do you celebrate Pride Month it's so
funny to me I keep forgetting joonas
Pride Month because I live in Vermont in
Vermont is weird and Vermont has pride
in September I don't do like a ton of
stuff but I usually do March in the
parade and I have more often than not
performed as well because in Burlington
Vermont they have in in the park there
they have a performance base there with
LGBTQ performers on Pride and I am
usually among them I'm a geek from
myers-briggs do you know do you know
your MBT I I don't
I used to but I don't remember what it
was what are your preferred pronouns now
this one was actually asked by a lot of
people and for the purposes of this
channel stick with mail it's just it
it's just most appropriate it makes the
most sense here in life it's kind of
situational and I think it really
depends on how and where and when in and
what context you know me best and see me
best you know I told people who are sort
of experienced me in either a masculine
or feminine mindset like to cue off of
lipstick if I'm wearing lipstick let's
go feminine otherwise you know masculine
is probably more appropriate I kind of
just by now default to whatever makes
them whatever they tend to think of me
as so I mean I just have people in my
life who see me most in a male mode and
I figured they're gonna use male
pronouns or see me most in a female mode
I figure they're mostly gonna use female
I at this point that's kind of what I
roll with I don't get overly hung up or
even uppity about pronouns because I
know for me I can't just give a a simple
answer as you've seen so you know I'm
not gonna be too touchy about it do you
have any pets not not presently not
personally my daughter has a hamster
that's that's as close as I come though
I'm not really curious if you ever did
get any backlash over beer a wild so
yeah the last Q&A the the 10,000
subscriber Q&A was when I basically came
out with my gender fluidity on this
channel I'm an acknowledged the vir wild
channel as as also being me and I said
in that video that I expected some form
of backlash whether it was gonna be just
nasty comments or a whole bunch of
subscribers dropping me or something
like that there was actually pretty much
no backlash whatsoever as of this
recording there are only four thumbs
down votes on that and like the harshest
kind of comment that happened on that
video was you know what I don't
but I that's fine so I suffered pretty
much no pushback or backlash from that
which you know what sometimes the
internet surprises you in a good way not
often but sometimes in your review of
the Holy Terror which was a Big Finish
dr. whom you eluded that you don't like
mean-spirited criticism of religious
belief what is your opinion on religion
my opinion on religion is complicated
and then probably more than I'd prefer
to get into right now long story short I
was not raised in a in any religion so I
don't have that as part of my background
my issue that I was alluding to in that
review is just that I I have a severe
dislike of straw man arguments you know
when you take when you take a group of
people and you paint them in a narrative
and in a very condescending overly
stereotypical way to then point fun at
the caricature that you have put up on
screen of these types of people and I
die see it with a lot of things other
than just you know religious
representation but in geeky media it
happens enough that it really does annoy
me when a person of faith of some kind
becomes something to be mocked by the
supposed protagonists or heroes of the
story that really just irks me as a
thing what do you do for work quite a
few people ask this actually I work in
sales I don't want to get into specifics
but I it's not it's not like a vague oh
I sell opportunity now I actually sell
stuff I work for a company that actually
manufacture stuff I mean when I say so I
don't mean like I go door-to-door I be I
handle accounts I handle stores that
carry our product to sell it to
consumers so that's that's what I do
have you ever tried any British food
well yeah I honeymooned in London so yes
I have
and I had the best fish and chips in my
life over there what type of music do
you listen to I can't really break it
down to genre z' because like any genre
that i could say if i were to like put
that on as a shuffle list on spotify i'd
end up skipping most of the stuff i tend
to be really picky so instead i'm just
gonna give you kind of a spread of some
artists that are artists i actually own
more than one album from because there's
a lot of single albums that I own so
some of those would include a miracle of
sound pink Lindsey Stirling Weird Al
Blind Guardian I also have a lot of film
scores how old are you now as of this
recording I am 36 dogs or cats dogs
I do like cats but I I grew up with dogs
I'm a little bit more of a dog person
cats are great but if I have to pick one
it's gonna be dogs are you clean most of
the time or do you swear a lot I'm
assuming you mean in my personal life
because obviously I keep the channel
clean I yeah I swear a fair bit a heck
of a lot more than I do here obviously
do you read newspapers and world news as
little as I can possibly get away with
now there are a number of questions that
I did write down I was going to answer
but I I'm actually I'm gonna kind of not
I'm just gonna address why not there
were about three questions or so that
were basically asking for my political
views on several things like my thoughts
like what I considered to be my own
level of patriotism about the US would I
ever consider leaving the u.s. and what
would make me do that what my thoughts
on free speech were but it was really
specifically worded question what my
thoughts on the Second Amendment were
and all of those I'm going to say that
I'm not going to answer and it's not
because I don't have opinions on those
things I actually do I have fairly
strong opinions on most of them but
they're things that would take longer
than I want to put in a video like this
to it to explain in a way I will become
with but also beyond that I I've said
many times before I don't I don't want
to heal any people who disagree with me
I enjoy having conversations people
disagree with me as long as it can be
kept civil and I kind of don't want to
run the risk of alienating potentially
up to half my subscriber base by laying
my political feelings out to be you know
picked through and and potentially
lashed at so I mean you you differ on my
stuff you can probably get a sense of
where my politics land I I don't think
it's that hard to figure out but I kind
of don't want to lay out specifics of
that cuz I don't think it's particularly
relevant to this channel for the most
part have you ever visited Asia if so
where have you visited if not wish which
Asian country or countries would you
most like to visit and why on a related
note do you have a favorite cuisine
Japanese Chinese Thai etc okay I have
much like the stereotypical American I
haven't been outside of the US much and
pretty much everywhere I've gone if it
didn't have English as the predominant
language it was safe to assume that
pretty much everyone who lived there
spoke it I get really uncomfortable if I
can't if I feel like I can't communicate
with people if I can't speak the
language like it throws me off enough
going you know up into Canada to
Montreal we're sure pretty much ever we
can speak English but it's a second
language to to a lot of folks and most
of them speak French primarily so I
haven't traveled Asia I'm not saying I
never would I would probably need to go
with someone who did speak the language
so I would feel like I had that tether I
think it'd be most interested in
visiting Japan and as far as cuisine
goes I grew up on Chinese food but these
days I kind of favor Thai since these
stereotypical and caricature prison
since the stereotypical perception of a
typical geek is someone who wouldn't be
found in a Men's Health magazine do you
have any special activities or such to
offset the notion or
eating habits you have not really I mean
I I think I think I look decently but I
mean I've I've been trying to shed the
same weight that I would prefer not to
have for three or four years now so like
I I look okay and I'm perfectly happy
with the way I look I'm more or less but
I don't really do much and I know it's a
cop-out answer but I think up for a
certain degree its metabolism there I
come from a line of both sides of my
family of fairly slim fit men that's
kind of the default so I don't actually
have to do a lot to maintain this I just
have to avoid overdoing snacking or just
really bad things and you know trying
and get some exercise and but I don't do
much like I don't I don't work out I you
know I try and get steps in and whatnot
but yeah I don't work out I don't have a
specific diet that I strictly adhere to
I just I kind of wing it if you were to
end up in space picked up by a mad
person with a box falling through a rift
abducted saved at the last minute by a
friend it turns out to be from outer
space and not earth when earth was
demolished to make way for an
intergalactic hyperspace bypass or any
other way what are the five things you
would bring so if we're going things in
like I can't bring people let's go with
a notebook a pen my leather-bound copy
of Hitchhiker's Guide with galaxy my
phone cuz I'd like to assume whoever
took me off world could hook it up so it
would still work as if I was on earth
would you know a little bit of
jiggery-pokery and some headphones for
that can you balance a pint glass on
your head have you ever had a swim with
a dolphin and why are you such a nice
guy I've never tried I never have and am
i Thanks
I wonder do you spend more time as Vera
compared to your male appearance and do
you treat people differently or hold
different views while being Vera um
I don't spend more time as Vera actually
what I get what I've been doing more
often cuz what are you seeing right now
is kind of middle
ground because if I do full-on feminine
we're talking like it would it would be
something more feminine than a shirt
like this it will be full makeup it
would it would be a lot more involved I
don't I I kind of my default when I'm
not at work is this kind of middle
ground that you see right now it's it's
presenting more or less masculine but
with you know the the feminine hints the
Rings the glasses the the earrings and
then obviously the hair so that's that's
sort of where I default to these days
but I I'm comfortable presenting
masculine I'm comfortable presenting
feminine I'm comfortable doing this I
kind of default to this because it
allows me to get the best of both worlds
with not a ton of effort how did you
learn to not give a damn about what
other people think of you I mean I've
seen your hair colors you paint your
fingernails pretty much do your own
thing and too many people I know this
will come across as weird and
off-putting did you face a lot of
backlash for that in life and how do you
deal with it well um I've actually faced
very little backlash I mean I mentioned
already not really having much backlash
I've been coming out on the channel but
even in my life like I've never had a
significant person in my life reject me
over this
I've had people have questions but you
know I think that's pretty natural but
I've never had a family member a close
friend and I you know nobody like that
has ever rejected me and I actually have
yet to be publicly confronted about my
appearance about my presentation whether
it's this or you know going full
feminine about the worst of it that I've
ever gotten is you know walking by
somebody on the street who sort of looks
back as I passed and goes like what the
hell like but that's that's the worst of
it that I personally have experienced
now that's not to minimize or imply that
it's that easy for everybody I know I'm
very fortunate in terms of the people
that I have in my life friends and
family and the communities in which I've
lived and have been out
in and that's not the case and
everywhere and I'm extremely fortunate
as far as you know why I'm able to be as
relaxed as this it is just that I just
want to be be me and relaxed about it so
my my having a I don't really care what
people think attitude isn't a response
to people having slammed out on me it's
more a response to realizing most people
don't care so why should I worry whether
or not they do and finally last one how
are you I'm great
I really am I'm I am quite possibly at
the happiest point in my life over all
that I've ever been in I mean things
aren't perfect perfect there are
nitpicks but I have a home I like I pay
my bills and I have a job with that
enables me to do that reliably I have an
amazing child I have a great
relationship with her mother who's my
best friend I have a phenomenal partner
who I love dearly
I am mmm happier than I think I've ever
been on a consistent level when I look
at the mirror I see I see me and I feel
like more of the world sees me than ever
has before
and that's pretty much all come about
well not all but the some of those
pieces have only come in it come about
and last six months or six months or so
and I am I am great and I want to thank
you guys for your part in that your
subscriptions your views your words of
encouragement your comments your
questions your page around support sorry
I had to get the plug in there somewhere
I
I will probably still be doing this even
if the channel hadn't grown to what it
is maybe not with the same level of
frequency but I would still be doing
this because I enjoy doing this but to
realize that I there are people who that
there are over 20,000 people who like
what I say enough that they want to know
when I have something new to say that's
amazing so thank you thank you for
making something that I already wanted
to do even more fulfilling than it
already inherently was so I hope that
this video finds you all well thank you
for your questions thank you for your
support you are beautiful you are loved
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
you